hi i'm keanu and this is my recipe for a
fork flavored cheesecake
[Music]
this recipe is a total throwback to my
childhood back in elementary school we
had these magazines where you could
order christmas gifts for people and
they had this poor flavored cheesecake
where it was four individual cheesecakes
cut up into quarters but all put
onto
one piece of cardboard and i figured i
could probably try to make it all in one
pan
so what made this cheesecake a bit
tricky is that i wanted to divide up
four very liquidy fluid items the thing
that made the most sense to me was to
use ingredients that were already in a
cheesecake so i opted for graham
crackers so once i got through the
structural part of the recipe the next
challenge was the four flavors
cheesecakes are really fun because you
can flavor them with whatever you want
but each different flavoring component
has its own chemistry so each cheesecake
batter end up having its own texture and
consistency so i had to play around with
every single flavor to make sure one it
tasted really good because end of day
doesn't matter what a dessert looks like
if it does not taste good it doesn't
really matter and then also that it was
thick enough where once i put it in its
corner it didn't budge stayed put
but it was still like nice and creamy
once it was all set
when it came to choosing flavors the
number one obvious one was chocolate
i love chocolate everyone loves
chocolate and chocolate hazelnut spread
is really thick and creamy so i knew
once i fold it into the cheesecake
batter is going to be really thick and
would fold up now the other flavors not
so easy the second flavor i wanted to go
with was lemon because it's a non-baked
cheesecake i think lemon is a really
good bright fresh flavor it's like very
summery and it's honestly one of my
favorites so i use lemon curd because if
i put in lemon juice it would have been
way too runny and then i just added a
little bit more lemon curd on the top to
make it visually pleasing the third
flavor i used was
just for the plain jeans in the world
everyone needs something simple so i
just did a vanilla cheesecake but to
give it like a little bit more oomph and
make it just as pretty as everything
else i added some raspberry jam vanilla
berries classic combination so i just
swirled in the top to make it very
pretty and then added some fresh berries
on the edge
now the fourth and final flavor
[Music]
me
it the fourth and final flavor was meant
to be caramel but the consistency of
that varied
so much between every product i use some
were super runny some were so thick i
couldn't even fold them in and it was
really tough when i was testing this
recipe i thought the cheat cake was done
it was beautiful and then as we're
filming the beauty shots the caramel
completely fell apart it literally was
oozing out of the side of the pan
because there's way too much water in it
but our lovely friends in brazil have
created a great food product called
dolce de leche which has a very similar
taste to caramel but it's so smooth and
thick so once i figured to use that it
was smooth sailing from there
and all the flavors
were good to go
i wanted people to have the option of
having that like prized double flavor
slice of cheesecake where you cut a
quarter inch of what's on the left and
quarter on the right and you have like a
two for one special however i think all
the flavors go really well together but
i had to check so i tested double
forkfuls of all the flavors just to see
what went and the only one that really
didn't go too well was a lemon curd and
chocolate so in the final cheesecake i
put them on opposing ends and then
everything else was good from there
the most struggling part about
developing this recipe
was to make it simple i wanted to be
like very all levels friendly
it's easy to make things complicated
it's difficult to make them simple it's
my philosophy of recipe development this
video didn't take long at all to do
wow
took like a day
full play the cheesecake
cool